What's Baylan Skoll up to? Just how
powerful is Ezra? And, most importantly,
where the heck is Zeb? These are big questions
— and Ahsoka's latest episode holds the answers.
Episode 7 of Ahsoka finally reunites
Ahsoka Tano with Sabine Wren and Ezra
Bridger on Peridea — but the circumstances are
far from ideal. The Jedi's quest to assist her
allies in their fight against Baylan Skoll and
Shin Hati has allowed Grand Admiral Thrawn to
escape the planet and return to the known galaxy.
Clearly, our heroes are facing an uphill battle.
The latest installment of the Disney+ series
also includes some telling moments of dialogue,
adding more depth to certain
characters and addressing the
fates of others. So what might you have missed?
"A long time ago, in a galaxy far, far away…"
Ahsoka reunites most of the surviving members
of the Ghost crew from Star Wars Rebels,
but the current whereabouts of Zeb
was, until now, a mystery. However,
this question is answered when a conversation
between Sabine Wren and Ezra Bridger reveals
that he's currently training the next
generation of fighters for the New Republic.
"There's a New Republic, Zeb's training
recruits, and Hera's commanding a fleet."
While there are many Star Wars fans
out there who want to see him join
up with his old comrades again, it's
good to know that he's keeping busy.
Of course, Zeb's current role in the galaxy
far, far away was hinted at in The Mandalorian,
as he makes an appearance in that show's
third season. While this is basically a
throwaway scene in the grand scheme of things,
it suggests that Zeb will have a bigger role to
play in Disney+'s live-action Star Wars output
in the near future. With a war between the New
Republic and Grand Admiral Thrawn seemingly on
the horizon, Ahsoka and the gang will need all
of the allies they can find; Zeb's piloting and
combat skills will no doubt be extremely useful
to their mission. Fans will agree, of course,
that Zeb's comeback can't come soon enough.
And then there's Baylan
Skoll. Baylan — or, at least,
Dave Filoni — is clearly a scholar of
earthling history, as Ahsoka's first
season has seen him repeatedly reference quotes
from real-life historical figures. For example,
Episode 4 sees him pay homage to
Pablo Picasso when he proclaims that:
"One must destroy in order to create."
This quote essentially paraphrases
the great artist's mantra that "every
act of creation begins with an act of
destruction" — and it really makes you
wonder what Baylan's grand plan is really about.
Episode 7, meanwhile, sees Baylan directly quote
King Louis XIV when he tells Shin Hati that:
"Impatience for victory will guarantee defeat."
Given that the 17th-century French monarch
enjoyed a 72-year reign on the throne,
it's safe to say that he learned a thing
or two about playing the long game. This
is wise advice to give to an ambitious
warrior who craves power in her own right,
and it says a lot about Baylan's
mindset heading into the upcoming war.
But what do these historical quotes
mean for the former Jedi? For one thing,
they clearly show that he's willing to be
patient before initiating his secret master
plan. We already know that Baylan wants Thrawn
to start a war, presumably so he can rebuild
the galaxy from the ashes afterward. However, his
words to Shin in Episode 7 highlight the fact he
doesn't expect change to happen overnight — and
that he's probably harboring ulterior motives.
Back on the side of the angels, Ahsoka's
seventh episode displays Ezra Bridger's
new status as a full-on Force ninja — one who
doesn't need lightsabers or blasters to help
him win a fight. In the fight against
Shin and her minions, he tells Sabine:
"The Force is my ally. That's all I need."
After this, he defeats their foes using both
the Force and some good ol' fashioned brawling.
What's more, Ezra manages to block one of
Shin's lightsaber attacks with his mind,
which is a rare accomplishment even for
the most skilled Force wielders. That said,
Ezra isn't the first person to pull it
off; Darth Vader does the same to Reva
in Obi-Wan Kenobi when she tries to attack
him from behind with her own lightsaber.
Kylo Ren and Rey also master the
trick in The Rise of Skywalker.
This moment essentially confirms that Ezra
has mastered the ways of the Force — and
that he's nearly as formidable as some of
the most powerful beings in the galaxy.